[Music]
early voting continues across the
country as we head toward election day
on Tuesday but polling reveals record
dissatisfaction with both Democrats and
Republicans in 1994 the Pew Research
Center found six percent of Voters held
an unfavorable view of both parties
today that number has jumped to 27
percent now a group of breakaway
Republicans and Democrats has formed a
new group called The forward party Brook
Silva Braga met with their leadership as
they planned for this election day and
Beyond
number two is Austin what does it look
like to start a new political party that
one seat could be critical that one C
could be critical Christy Todd Whitman
the former Republican governor of New
Jersey and Andrew Yang the one-time
Democratic candidate for president are
finding out there are other parties out
there there's a green party there's a
Libertarian party but I think what
you're attempting is different or bigger
than that when was the last time someone
in America accomplished what you're
attempting well nobody really has well I
guess you could say the Republican party
that's how it started it's a third party
we're talking 1860. right exactly it was
a while ago ever since Republicans and
Democrats have controlled America's
government and the forward party argues
the growing Us Versus Them conflict
between the parties there's nothing
smart about you Joe is at the root of
America's current problems you're the
worst president America has ever had
we have to reimagine what American
politics can be because this version is
going to tear us apart it's going to
lead to Strife Bloodshed dysfunction and
worse we've seen it your enemy is not
your fellow American it's not your
friend and neighbor but it's a system
that actually profits from turning us
against each other what does the forward
Party stand for we stand for free people
thriving communities and a vibrant
democracy and we'll have a platform but
it's not going to be the kind of
platform that people are used to seeing
meaning it won't be that specific on
policy the party is staking out mostly
Centrist often vague positions because
they say most Americans are themselves
centrists who just want to see things
get done even on issues as contentious
as abortion most people believe in some
form of choice for women 15 weeks 20
weeks it used to be 20 weeks you can get
people there but we're being told no you
can't they don't want to solve the
problems because they want to use them
against the other side George W bush
sent a bill to the hill on immigration
reform and it was a place to start they
never even held hearings on it neither
side wanted to give the other a win
two-thirds of Americans say we ought to
have more than two parties Lee Drummond
is a political scientist at the new
America foundation so why don't we
well we don't because we have a system
of Elections that makes it hard for
third parties to compete dozens of other
democracies have some form of
proportional representation a party
winning 20 percent of the vote gets
roughly 20 percent of the seats 19 to
Ross Perot in the U.S winning 20 percent
of the vote gets you nothing but
Governor Clinton got an overwhelming
majority in the decisive electoral vote
you tend to have just two parties
because votes for anything other than
one of the top two parties winds up
being wasted in his book breaking the
two-party Doom Loop dropman recommends a
change that would help third parties
having fewer larger congressional
districts but electing several people
from each one finishing third would make
you a congressperson enacting some kind
of electoral reform is so essential to a
third party's chances it's become the
forward party's core priority that only
two policy positions that we really ask
of people is open primaries and ranked
Choice voting open primaries and ranked
Choice voting are already being used in
a few places including recently Alaska
in a contest for an open Congressional
see this past summer 48 candidates
competed in a single Open primary
including Republican Sarah Palin and
Nick begich Independents like Al gross
and Democrats including Mary peltola the
top four Advanced though gross dropped
out then in the general election voters
ranked their choices in order of
preference the candidate with the fewest
first place votes baggage was eliminated
and his votes redistributed to those
voters second choice because many of
them preferred the Democrat to his
fellow Republican peltola who finished a
fourth in the primary won the seat you
have right now Independents are on the
outside looking in and if you give
Independence a real voice then you wind
up with different results and our
recommended changes don't Advantage One
party or another they Advantage the
voters while the Party Works to
popularize the new rules it needs to
thrive it's also trying to influence the
system as it is by endorsing
independent-minded candidates this cycle
and planning to run their own
Congressional and Senate candidates in
2024 but not necessarily a presidential
ticket we'll do anything we can to make
sure that Donald Trump does not get near
the White House and so we would not in
any way be a spoiler in that kind of a
contest so if he's the nominee you would
not run for president if to do so would
be to increase the odds of him winning
no so why even care about a fledgling
party that might not even run for
president well forward says it could
manage a shortcut to power in Just the
next few months using something called
the fulcrum strategy in Utah forward is
backing independent Evan McMullen in his
race for Senate against Republican Mike
Lee how many senators does it take to
determine policy at this this point it
might just be one and there's a chance
that the forward party can have like
that kind of power you're hoping it's
Evan McMullen well you know if it's not
Evan uh it could be someone else though
I will say Evan's already said he's not
going to caucus without their parties so
that he could functionally be the
fulcrum as early as January of next year
which is what the country wants whether
the country wants the forward party is
yet to be voted on drupman says a
successful third party will probably
have to stake out more specific
compelling policy positions than forward
has so far but as someone longing for
reform drupman hopes Americans interest
in change won't be limited to who we
vote for but how we vote too we tend to
view our system as fixed as unchangeable
as you know we just gotta muddle through
but it's not fixed it's not unchangeable
we've changed it throughout our history
we're not fated to be Sleepwalkers into
a a democratic collapse we can choose
for CBS Saturday morning Brook
silvabrago Washington
two-thirds of Americans would like to
see more than two major political
parties and people want a voice yeah I
want to feel heard it makes sense I mean
that idea open primaries would help that
yeah right with the idea that all it
takes is that one especially in the
Senate you particularly you've seen it
with Joe manchin making a difference but
wow they're being smart about it they're
looking at those individual races down
the line before they hit the
presidential
yeah it'll be interesting to watch it oh
yeah two years they're also making their
own decisions though at the end right
which is an interesting part of it it's
not completely listening to voters so
yes of course